bernard moraine le maire de joigny nous
attend justement en direct bonsoir
bernard moraine réélection rappelle
qu'il y avait une triangulaire avec le
front national présent dans votre ville
ce soir
ben oui puis finalement on a repoussé le
front national qui était à près de douze
ennemis % au premier tour et qui est ce
soir à 8% et on remporte 7
cette victoire ça fait vraiment du bien
on a donné tout ce qu'on avait on a
présenté un joli bilan qui était
difficile dans une ville comme vous le
savez qui a été victime de la rgpp de la
fermeture de de sa caserne en
particulier qui est une ville en
souffrance et on va pouvoir terminer le
travail qu'on a commencé source est si
proche prochaines années il y en a
bonsoir bernard moraine
est ce que le fait de ne pas avoir
d'étiquette parti socialiste dans le dos
était un avantage pour vous dans cette
élection
lilian je vais vous faire un scoop je
suis de gauche et je suis un maire
jamais rouvert à tout le monde
je suis un maire 2100 jours c'est ça
c'est la durée d'un mandat ou je suis
auprès de la population je parle à tout
le monde
j'ai mes convictions j'ai mes valeurs je
les ai toujours défendu
je crois que ce sont tous des valeurs
d'humanisme et oui je suis de gauche
mais j'ai été aussi capable de
rassembler des gens qui n'était pas de
gauche et on va travailler tous ensemble
pour mouiller le maillot de l'équipe de
joigny